قال منسق الامم المتحده الخاص لعمليه
السلام في الشرق الاوسط تور وينلاند ان
حجم الموت والدمار في غزه لم يسبق له مثيل
ولا يمكن تحمله واضاف ان ان نظام
الاستجابه الانسانيه اصبح على حفه
الهويه لا يزال ايصال المساعدات
الانسانيات في القطاع يواجه تحديات لا
يمكن التغلب عليها تقريبا وسط نزوح على
نطاق لا يمكن تصوره وقتال نشط اضحى نظام
الاستجابه الانسانيه على حافه الهاويه ان
الخطوات المحدوده التي اتخذتها اسرائيل
بما في ذلك السماح بدخول المزيد من الوقود
والغاز وغاز الطهي وفتح معبر كرم ابو سالم
لدخول الامدادات الانسانيه هي خطوات
ايجابيه لكنها لا ترقى الى ما هو مطلوب
لمعالجه الكارثه الانسانيه على الارض ان
حجم القتال بين اسرائيل وحماس ونطاق الموت
والدمار في غزه لم يسبق له مثيل ولا
يطاق